bonsoir docteur courage dans ce monsieur
roux alors c'est à peu près ce qu'on
avait prévu ce qui était sorti c'est à
dire on va permettre d'aller au cinéma
avec les enfants d'aller se baigner avec
les enfants d'aller jouer au parc avec
un peu plus de monde donc avec des amis
huit personnes activités extérieures
est ce que pour vous d'abord comme
médecin de votre perspective c'est
prudence et c'est correct
je pense que oui je pense qu'il faut
permettre aux enfants et aux plus
grandes d'avoir des activités puis à
l'extérieur honnêtement moi j'ai pas
d'enjeu qu'on soit 4,8
le risque est le même c'est à dire assez
faible et puis à l'intérieur quand il ya
des activités avec port du masque avec
une bonne situation je pense que c'est
tout à fait sécuritaire aussi les
beaucoup de questions emporté lors du
point de presse sur le noël en disant
est ce qu'on risque de connaître l'homme
dans deux semaines donc la semaine de
relâche ce qu'on a connu pendant le
congé des fêtes c'est à dire des
rassemblements et donc que la courbe
repartent vers le haut est ce que c'est
ce que vous craignez pas ce que vous
pensez qu inévitablement les cobras ont
augmenté pas inévitablement c'est sûr
que ça fait partie des possibilités des
risques je pense que on essaie toujours
de faire confiance aux gens nous faisant
comprendre que les rassemblements
intérieur c'est paul moment que oui
c'est souvent plus facile de garder
trois familles ensemble mais on n'est
pas capable présentement de faire et on
ne devrait pas le faire donc des
activités organisées où on porte le
masque et où on édite en sus ça va oui
mais ça fait ça fait partie des craintes
mais en même temps je pense qu'on peut
pas faire autrement oui parce que les
besoins de bouger puis pour les familles
la bande et ça devient le remède
pourrait devenir pire en fait à tout à
fait tout à fait je pense que ce qui est
proposé est un et un bonnet un juste
équilibre
je ne sais pas si j'avais eu l'occasion
d'écouter tout le point de presse ce qui
m'a frappé c'est docteur arruda d'abord
à utiliser une expression dont et aux
derniers mails de ce marathon la
vaccination arrivent monsieur lavoie dit
j'aimerais bien savoir quels seront les
hospitalisations dans deux ou trois
semaines je ne sais pas mais si tout va
bien on va annoncer début mars
mi mars d'autres assouplissements on a
l'impression qu'on se croise les doigts
et que malgré les variants on se dit que
les choses peuvent quand même
s'améliorait pas mal dans les prochaines
semaines mais je pense que ce qu'on se
dit c'est que jusqu'à maintenant les
variants n'ont pas semblé se transmettre
plus que ça dans le sens où il ya eu du
criblage qui a été débutée du séquençage
a été fait il semble qu'ils n'en avaient
pas trouvé tant que ça
maintenant si à chaque éclosion de
varier on a réussi à le contenir
c'est une très bonne nouvelle je pense
qu'on est déjà en train de célébrer mais
je pense que comme le premier ministre
de dire si on peut avoir un printemps
hâtif pouvoir aller se voir d'or on voit
ce emporté nettement mieux
puis c'est vrai que en théorie les doses
de vaccins sans vie dont l'essence y en
avoir six millions pour le canada du la
fin mars
comme à peu près rien qui rentrait
jusqu'à maintenant le gros devrait
rentrer à partir de maintenant et il ya
plus il ya plusieurs millions de doses
de phase i/ii moderna qui ont été
commandés aussi pour le deuxième
trimestre donc en théorie les vaccins
devraient être leurs on devrait être
capable de vacciner puis à ce moment là
même avec une première dose
on voit quand même des gens qui ont une
efficacité puisqu'il ya à peu près plus
d'éclosion ch et celle des et les
personnes ans et celle c'est ainsi
accéder n'ont reçu qu'une dose et malgré
leur âge avancé elle ont malgré tout
bien répondu ça c'est la grande grande
éclaircies dans toute cette histoire là
on voit qu'un vaccination semble
fonctionner ça tient le coup à quel
moment vous pensé parce que l'on annonce
prenons pour le québec la 90 mille doses
cette semaine 90 milles 12 votre chemin
à quelle maman va de façon plus générale
voir l'effet la vaccination mais ça va
on va commencer à la voir quand je
voudrais que la grande majorité des
personnes âgées de 60 ans et plus vont
avoir été vacciné parce que c'est
vraiment elle surtout les 70 ans et plus
se sont vraiment elle qui sont les plus
à risque d'hospitalisations et de décès
même quand on prend en compte les
conditions médicales sous jacente tous
les autres facteurs de risque
le facteur de risque principe
les majeures c'est l'âge avancé donc
quand les 70 ans et plus un rpa et dans
la communauté vont avoir été vacciné je
pense qu'on va avoir un certain soupir
de soulagement
je pense que ce qui est aussi très
intéressant c'est que les variants qui
vient d'un grand bretagne semble quand
même être couvert par les deux vaccins
qu'on a présentement
donc ça aussi ce sont des bonnes
nouvelles pour le moment donc bon il
s'agit pas comme vous dites de célébrer
mais on peut dire qu'on a il est à peu
près certain à moins qu'on soit très
malchanceux on a traversé le pire
j'espère tout à fait j'espère que le
pire est passé je voudrais que à la
rentrée du temps des fêtes quand comme
quand ils se sont mis à baisser
on savait qu'il y avait du vaccin que ça
allait bien je dis une bouffée
d'optimisme qui s'est un peu assombri
avec l'arrivée des variants mais le si
on réussit à voir que les variants sont
quand même bien contrôlé par les vaccins
qu'on a présentement ça va je pense que
l'éclaircie va s'en venir de façon plus
personnelle
bon ben souhaitons le docteur couach est
toujours un plaisir de vous parler merci
beaucoup merci pour les lumières à
bientôt
alors